a court in hong kong is due to sentence
three pro-democracy activists after they
pleaded guilty to charges relating to
last year's anti-government protests
leading pro-democracy activist joshua
wong is appearing alongside agnes ciao
under ivan lam for inciting an illegal
assembly in june beijing imposed a
national security law on hong kong after
the territory was rocked by mass
protests
critics say the law is being used to
silence dissidents
well let's go straight to hong kong and
speak with the w correspondent
phoebe kong okay that's clearly a
not phoebe kong bear let's see if we can
uh
ah there she is welcome uh phoebe what
more can you tell us about this verdict
well we haven't got the uh verdict yet
the court hearing has already started
um like uh less than an hour ago but uh
we're still waiting for the judge to
announce the actual judgment and as you
have
mentioned in the report that joshua wong
is now facing uh three charges
uh including inciting and organizing and
also taking part in an
unflawed in an uh unapproved assembly
uh back in june in 2019 shortly since
the massive anti-government
movements broke out last year so um
joshua wong decided to plead guilty to
the first two charges including inciting
and organizing the
unauthorized assembly while the
prosecutor agreed to
offer no evidence to the third charge so
joshua is now
facing up to two convictions and which
could like bring him
sent him behind bars for up to five
years so we're still waiting for the
verdict and
also the uh the two other leading
activists they also
uh pleaded guilty to the charges um they
faced so uh we're still waiting for the
work verdict and
uh joshua wong has already mentioned
like before
that he is not optimistic to the
sentence that uh he expected
the sense the sentence will be like um
much heavier than
those he faced in the past okay uh
phoebe stay with us and
we'll find out more about joshua wong
and then we'll come back to you
hong kong 2014 the umbrella movement
takes to the streets four months of
protests spurred by a government plan
to pre-screen candidates for local
elections joshua wong was front and
center
[Applause]
everybody here has to stay alert this
demonstration has been peaceful
and the police haven't bothered us much
but now they've brought tear gas and
plastic bullets
we have to do all we can to protect
ourselves
[Music]
he was arrested at the age of 17.
wong became an international political
figure
in 2016 he founded a new political party
democisto aiming to define hong kong's
long-term future
wong himself was too young to be a
candidate though that didn't stop him
from trying to run for office
in 2019 he was jailed for two months but
went free in time to join
widespread protests over a proposed new
extradition law
to mainland china this time around the
demonstrations were much more violent
wong was arrested along with thousands
of others
in july 2020 things went from bad to
worse for pro-democracy activists
china passed the new security law for
hong kong that made
wang's democisto party illegal the party
disbanded and wong went to trial for his
activities in last year's protests
undeterred
he told dw in a recent interview he
would not back down
prison bars never stopped me from
activism and thinking critically
even in such difficult timing more than
ten thousand hong kong
were arrested since last summer and two
thousand people including me were
prosecuted
it's still important for us to stay and
fight
despite his defiance wong's sentence
will likely keep him out of the public
eye
for several years
let's pick up that point with uh phoebe
kong in hong kong
uh phoebe we're presuming that he's
going to be
uh the three of them are going to be
sentenced to jail
what sort of terms are they looking at
well um the charges they are facing is
inciting
and organizing an unauthorized assembly
which
like carries a maximum sentence of five
years
and um they're facing more than one
charges that that means they could face
like
more than like five years if uh if they
have to surf the sentence
like separately but uh we're still
waiting for the actual verdict
um so it's not like clear that of like
um like exactly how many years they're
going to place that behind us but
it's quite likely they will send to jail
and um
we have to remind uh bear in mind that
like this is not the first time for
joshua want to be
imprisoned he has already been jailed
for
two times like over the past two years
because of the charges he faced
back in the umbrella movement but that
only uh
brought him like a two to three month
jail sentence
uh in the past but at this time he
expected that the
he will be sent to jail for like over a
year or
or maybe several years um so uh so this
is
the expectation and um given the
circumstances in hong kong nowadays that
people
are really like not optimistic that um
the court may
uh try to impose a heavier sentence to
play um
to uh to deter people from committing
such crimes in the future
right because this this this is clearly
beijing sending a very
clear message about the hong kong
democracy
yeah yeah and this is uh th this will be
another major blow and setback to the um
opposition came as well like um while
the beijing would see
it as a kind of factory that for them to
uh crack down on the opposition and
anti-government movement and also the
leading activists that joshua wong is
the most high profile
figures to be sentenced to jail like if
he is today
that he will be the most like
high-profile uh leading activists to be
jailed since the
massive anti-government movement last
year so
this is really like an iconic and
landmark sentence in hong kong today
okay phoebe in hong kong thank you
straight to hong kong then to speak with
a member of the protester movement there
he doesn't want to reveal his identity
so we're calling him connor
welcome to dw uh what's likely to happen
today
oh sorry you mean
about the courts in court yes
right yes i don't think the courts will
be ruling in their favor
and once again joshua along with his
other comrades are being made martyrs of
the larger movement
but uh despite all this sadness i think
he put it very well
it's important for us now to keep our
heads clear and to move forward
because uh backing down is not an option
anymore
have you had any contact with any of the
activists
being sentenced today
uh no i haven't right so how worried
then are you about your own safety
well i think uh most hong kong was with
me
and uh especially having participated in
this movement i guess
my level of fear would be on par with
most other hong kongers that have also
been actively participating
but um it's more about there's more
anger than fear i'd say
uh having seen what's been happening for
the past week
so given the crackdowns that is
happening given that the law changes
that
are happening can your pro-democracy
fight continue
definitely yeah i think domestic
resistance has changed its form
but it's still going very strong very
much so um
although joshua wong and other more
prominent figures are
arrested i do believe and i have seen
that
a lot of other independent actors are
still working about to push this
movement forward in the city and aside
from that on the international stage
a lot of good work is being done by uh
such as the uh
ecstatic system member nathan law people
like them are still
fighting hard abroad so yeah there's
hope i think
okay but we're in the time of covid now
when um
it's when uh lots of uh governments are
acting against
uh crowds gathering so what sort of
resistance can you
um uh put up uh under these sort of
circumstances
um thank you so even though crowd
gatherings are now banned and it might
seem like
everything is now has now quiet down um
i think organizing people
in preparation for eventual end of the
lockdown
for larger for even larger voices to be
heard
that is something that can be done so
organizing beforehand i think a lot of
that work
can be done now
china is clearly not going to back down
on this
why are you continuing
well um they really are for me
personally i can't speak for anyone
but uh the first thing would be
it's a duty to serve our larger hong
kong
nation i think uh in the past year it's
been
felt in the hearts and minds of the hong
kong people this sense of nationhood and
so at this point more than out of
empathy and sympathy for the protest is
small
of a duty to serve i think and that's
the motivation that's keeping us forward
and yes it's a hard fight
china's cracking down on us and not just
us on australia and
on a lot of other sovereignty sovereign
nations as well but um
yeah it's only it only shows how um
afraid the uh tyrannical government is
now
they're now losing their patience losing
their calm
and this is now our time to strive right
so
given that i just wonder how long you
can continue
this fight because again clearly beijing
has more time and more resources
and and is determined that it must win
this battle
yes um so
of course um our time is very limited
and that's why we have to act faster
we see that a lot of
a lot of brainwashing work is being done
in our education system in hong kong
and i think it's fair to say that uh
these couples generations of passionate
youths are the last
generations of passionate youths that we
will see
and um yeah i think as soon as these
couple of generations die out
the movement will probably end with that
and um i mean
because there's nobody else left here to
sustain the uh
unity of the nation but um yeah uh
but there is hope i think right uh we
just have to
yeah okay well thank you so much for
joining us
never felt them thank you